you know I never made it past the random
number generator filter so the the only
way Gordon was volunteering to do this
yeah yeah so Tiki DM Tucker do more take
care of the mass the other have them
pronounce it it's one of the world's
most popular Python packages six million
downloads last month I think half a
million people have read the
documentation it's hard coded into
anaconda because Conda hasn't heard of
get sub-modules anyway um yeah so what
is it it's just a it's a progress meter
so if you go to any of these landing
pages the first thing you'll probably
notice cuz I can be it's a gift I'll go
through all the features shown here plus
hopefully a few which you haven't heard
of before for those of you don't know
this library let's say you take a simple
for loop in Python and you're wondering
when will it end
so with the simple four characters of
code T qdm you can wrap any in trouble
and you get this nice progress bar for
free
it's wonderful cuz it works in the
terminal Windows Linux Mac Jupiter
notebooks basically everywhere we also
provide this T range convenience
function so that's down to one extra
character of code now to get an extra
progress bar it supports the same
options as T gdm itself so you can add a
custom description a bunch of other bar
format arguments as well I'll go through
some other optional arguments later and
of course you can use this outside your
Python modules on the command line
itself so if you use T key them to you
know measure the throughput of a pipe in
terms of number of lines per second or
bytes per second if you specify total
you get a full progress bar as well and
so why use this obviously it's
incredibly easy to use we pay attention
to overhead as well
worst case scenario even if you have an
empty for loop where all it's doing is
displaying a progress bar it still
nanoseconds we have intelligent
estimated time remaining unlike windows
file copy 2 hours 3 days infinity yeah
we don't do that works works in anything
which is you know equally broken
cross-platform but hey
Jupiter notebooks as I mentioned and it
has no defenses than any other Python
modules so quick recap of usage you can
wrap any insurable character arrays
numpy arrays whatever pandas it just
works you don't have to wrap it within a
for loop you can create a tiki name
object outside and then called member
earth is let's just set description and
things like that you don't even need an
interval at all you can just create a
taking an object with
total and call update as in when you
feel like it and if you do this try and
treat the progress bar but like a file
object so use the with syntax or use the
closed syntax it's just good programming
practice if you're using it as a module
I recommend you use the Python 3 version
simply because python 3 is a little more
efficient when it comes to dealing with
standard input and output but feel free
to use just a Python 2 version if you
want to so for example say you're
printing out all the lines of code in
your Python files in Linux this is the
command is the TDM version some fancy
bar forms and sing arguments here as
well say you're backing up a directory
take your damn version again specifying
a total so you get a nice progress bar
7-zip equivalents in case you're
interested in terms of documentation
import tqm run help if you're in a
notebook tkm question mark and on the
command line help of course you've got
more options than you can shake a
keyboard at so there's also the examples
folder online the wiki there's this
Jupiter notebook itself you don't have
to install Jupiter or anything you can
just run it within your browser click
those two buttons and here's the
interesting bit of the talk so for those
of you actually have used this before so
we have member functions which you might
find useful set description set post fix
is particularly nice because it takes
any arbitrary list of arguments and
tries it's best to pretty format them so
pretty useful for machine learning that
sort of thing we also have things like
the bar format to completely customize
exactly what your bar looks like really
abusing Python formatting notation to
use this postfix thing in order to you
know access nested dictionaries and
things like that and we support that's
the progress bars as well so you can
have multiple bars displaying on top of
each other if you're using this on the
command line on Windows you might have
to install colorama as a dependency to
make it less broken we we also allow you
to specify a position just in case
you're doing multi-threaded stuff in
order to get the bars displaying
correctly on top of each other than the
right order if you trying to use this
with you own external libraries you can
use callbacks so for example say you're
downloading with something with URL Lib
here's the Tiki dam version most of this
is just a simple wrapper so Tiki dam has
this update which expects Delta
iteration so number of iterations
elapsed since you lost called it update
and URL Lib wants an update to which is
the total number of iterations called so
far so that's just four lines
code giving it to this report hook as
URL live calls it again we're being
fancy here specifying units as bytes and
unit scaling that sort of thing and you
get this nice progress you can specify
total and that would be a progress bar
yeah if you're doing some machine
learning say it Terrace model and you
did model outfit this is the annoying
sort of output you might get and and
then again with three or four lines code
you can you can give this little wrapper
and get this nice tedium in progress bar
we have pandas rappers as a mansion so
you can do a series map apply goop by
progress apply that sort of thing and of
course we have no quick integration so
you can import TN range and for notebook
or tkm notebook mix and maximum wrap
them up have nested progress bars it
just works here's a gif of what that
sort of looks like nice attention to
detail it'll turn red if you break out
of a progress bar halfway through or
turned green when it's completed and if
you're not sure whether your end users
are using a Jupiter notebook or going to
be running their code in the command
line you can always import from TQM Auto
which will automatically figure out what
your front end is and I'd like to finish
with this quick graphic tweet which went
viral about a year ago I think
highlighting how few people are
responsible for maintaining some of the
world's most you know popular numerical
Python packages and here's the Technium
version as well just reaching out so
sure
[Applause]